gefällt mir hier sehr die berg die
schönheit natur und die ruhe gefehlt
wenn die leute mehr klar denken laut
musik weil die musik muss laut sein
laut allein reicht nicht es ist marian
us energie dies ausmacht unter bildes
die nächste band gruß mariana der cruze
ist 41 lebt seit bald zehn jahren in
bern
ganz anders ihre kindheit in einer
kleinstadt im bundesstaat sao paulo aus
als jüngstes von sechs kindern nach
einer ausbildung zur lehrerin suchte sie
ihr glück mit musik in europa in
lissabon wurde der berner elektro
musiker eine hebeisen auf sie aufmerksam
die beiden schmiedeten ein zeitgemäßes
brasilianisches musikprojekt und sind
seither ein paar die schweiz ein
günstiger nährboden für ihre kreativität
und präzision
was mache ich auch hier ist das gefühl
das ist schon ziemlich als schwein zu
demnach in die schweiz gekommen ist hat
sie eigentlich will bedienen
außer vielleicht jenes der lebensfreude
sei dass das viel besungene heimweh ist
ihr hingegen fremd
diese heimweh ich denke dass du nicht
wirklich deine leben seite gehen wenn du
denkst aber ich habe sehr passiv was
dort habe ich etwas besser dort gelassen
aus hier nein ich habe in meinem kopf
okay hier ich muss hier leben und neue
sachen entdecken
kritische gedanken ganz unverdächtig als
samba getan
die spur progresso das vierte album der
band eine virtuos arrangierte außensicht
auf die aktuellen sozialen probleme
brasiliens ich habe ein bisschen mehr
augen auch von situation von was
passiert genau drinnen werden du bist
bringen in die land bis involviert jeden
tages begleichen
bist du ein bisschen betäubt
mit der zelle so mitfiebern muss aber
dennoch sein
freud und leid einer brasilianerin
gewarnt
die band hat sich etabliert und spielt
heute konzerte in deutschland frankreich
und kanada
das leben war gut zu mir so marianne der
gruß musikalisches fazit etwas liegt er
noch besonders am herzen
präsident wir sind auch modern offen und
wir mussten diese fortschritte machen
progress